the atlanta braves with a chance to
clinch their third straight division
title tonight with a win over the miami
marlins they'll have bryce wilson on the
mound starling martay will be the batter
hitting 290
at the pitch he is caught on a miss well
that was a good sequence took a little
longer than bryce would have liked but
i'm sure he's happy with the result the
swing of the miss and can jose arena
lead the way on the mound set a good
pace good tempo and get deep into the
game tonight for tomorrow
marcelo zuna steps in here batting 316.
high fly ball hit deep toward left
center field dickerson will watch that
one sail away ozona hits a solo homer
with two outs and the braves strike
first in the first marcelo zuna
launches one over the left field wall
and it's one-nothing braves on his 16th
home run of the season
and we all bees marques and reilly for
the braves here in the bottom of the
second inning as ozzie albee's drives
the first pitch deep towards center
martin going back at the 400 sign he
won't get it a splashdown homer ferrazzi
and ozzy albees drills one over the
centerfield wall
two-nothing rays on his sixth home run
of the year
and quite the spectacle in the sky as
that ball is sailing out
runners move up to second and third for
austin reilly
one-two pitch a swing and a foul tip
into the catcher's mid alfaro able to
hang on that was that four-seam fastball
up one down alvaro struck out in the
third
a 3-2 pitch
swung on and missed struck him out
good fastball right at the knees
strikeout number seven for wilson corey
dickerson
has two of the marlins three hits three
singles corey has two of them
jesus aguilar has the other one
the 2-2
change up popped up
behind third tough play dansby riley
duvall it's duvall who calls for it he's
got it and that's a three-up and
three-down inning for wilson his first
of the night we go to the bottom of the
fifth braves up two to nothing here's
marcelo zuna who homered in the first
inning hitting his 16th of the year
ozuna digs back in arena to work freddie
takes off fly ball down the right field
line that's curling away from joyce that
ball is down it's off the base of the
wall one run scores freddie around third
he's going to score without a play they
put him in motion and the braves get two
more runs what an at-bat by marcelo zuna
and the ending's not over here's duvall
he's grounded out and walked
eight hits including five home runs
against the marlins this year here's a
high fly ball right field coming in
under it joyce he's there makes the
catch and the inning finally comes to an
end
martay has struck out and popped up
and he did that right there that's
exactly what he did get out
boom and the marlins just like that are
on the scoreboard martay long home run
to center his sixth and the marlins now
trail by three it's a 4-1 game two out
on the inning for aguilar who is singled
and walked
the pitch
hammer toward third oh what a pick up
riley
great play and a perfect throw and look
at aguilar he cannot believe it that's
two times in as many games the marlins
have hit an absolute rocket to the hot
corner and riley has robbed him
atlanta's got swanson acuna and freeman
do
here in the seventh
as dansby jumps on the first one hammers
that down the line off nick vincent that
ball is deep that ball is gone first
pitch home run for dansby swanson bombs
away in atlanta ga the braves have hit
three more home runs tonight
bombs away for dansby for the eighth
time this season and the braves get that
run back to the game up in the sixth and
it's now a 5-1 lead and here's freddie
freeman who had hit last time he's one
out of three
look at freddie he's going to go deep
he's going to go yard freddie freeman's
back with a bag
on two homer inning for atlanta
freeman's 12th he's got 50 rbis
and the braves have blown this game wide
open against the marlins it's now 7-1 in
the seventh
i think marcakus looks to get in on the
hitting fun the braves have 12 safeties
tonight that go for three
shot toward right joyce came in a step
and
misplayed it it's off his glove a run is
in streaking toward third is ozzie and
he'll reach safely
here's austin reilly now with men at the
corners
line driving to center field that's
going to score all bees marcakis will
stop at second the braves play at
station to station
the braves man around here in the seven
that'll bring dansby back up to the
plate
it will be a 2-2 pitch to swanson
and it will be a strikeout for eichner
one out now brian anderson
who is over three tonight
broken bat line drive quick throw to
second and they got him
martay wandered too far off the second
base bag and the braves somehow someway
get out of it a broken bat double play
off the bat of brian anderson ozuna got
it all started for atlanta solo home run
in the first inning
fly ball that is belted deep left center
field ozuna's done it again
his second home run of the night
he has a five rbi night and the braves
are pounding the marlins 11-1
home run number 17 that gives him the
team lead
braves leading 11-1 one out away from
clinching the national league east
catcher jorge alfaro up here to bat
strike one to el faro line drive caught
by freddie freeman it's a three-peat for
the braves they're the champions of the
east in 2020.